es una buena noticia para la protección
de la amazonía brasileña este lunes el
enviado especial para la protección del
medio ambiente de Estados Unidos John
Kerry llegó a Brasil para reunirse con
el gobierno de Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva su objetivo principal recaudar
fondos para conservar el mayor bosque
del mundo algo crucial en estos momentos
Kerry y yo Tuvimos una conversación
preliminar sobre los temas que serán
objetivo de una empresa conjunta
anunciada
cuando tengamos el resultado del trabajo
conjunto en temas como el clima el fondo
de la amazonía O la cooperación de
Brasil Estados Unidos
lo anunciaremos
Y es que la lucha contra la
deforestación y la protección de la
amazonía fue una de las promesas de
campaña de Lula que su gobierno parece
estar decidido a cumplir Para ello el
presidente ya anunció que planeaba pedir
ayuda a otros países ricos
como ya he hecho con Noruega o Alemania
y como hizo durante su visita Estados
Unidos a principios de este mes
sentí una gran voluntad por parte del
presidente biden de participar en la
creación de un fondo en el que
participen todos los países
desarrollados del mundo para que
intentemos cuidar mejor de nuestro
planeta
la razón para pedir esta ayuda Es que la
amazonía es patrimonio del mundo y
cuidarla es una responsabilidad
compartida El Ejecutivo brasileño ha
dejado Claro que siempre estará Bajo su
potestad Pero quiere intentar reparar al
máximo la deforestación y degradación
del bioma tras años especialmente duros
para el mayor bosque del mundo